let's go next to our caller from the
five one two area code who's calling
today from five one two hey can you hear
me yeah who's this
hi David my name is Joe I've been a
longtime listener great great to hear
from you Joe okay so here's my question
hmm so no doubt it's been going around
like Twitter feeds yesterday that uh
that article 13 was passed and you and
immediately never on the same day there
the house was having it's a decision on
HR 1644 aka the stains in that act which
will restore the net neutrality
protections that chairman PI gutted so
I'm so I'm just curious I want your
opinion this David why do you think the
news hasn't been a covering net
neutrality and I don't mean like well
like tech sites or blogs or anything
like that like the mainstream news CNN
MSNBC etc but that's not a new thing you
know so I've we've talked about this
before there's very little upside to big
media covering net neutrality number one
they stand to lose as establishment
legacy media the more there is actual
net neutrality Internet freedom
regulation the more corporate media
stands to lose their sort of privileged
position or potentially what what they
see it as being disadvantage but it's
really just trying to sort of equalize
the playing field so this has been a
trend for years I mean corporate media
has barely covered net neutrality when
the fight for net neutrality was
happening under Obama when the repeal of
Obama era regulations related to net
neutrality were taking place early in
the Trump administration that's not a
new thing there's just no upside for
corporate media for covering that
because corporate media whether you
identify MSNBC as being left or Fox News
as being right or whatever editorial
bias they they have they don't want to
get into questioning the infrastructure
that allowed them to get so big and
allowed media consolidation to happen
net neutrality is connected to that they
don't want to touch it
well I also figured that with some news
organizations being owned by ISPs like I
don't need Comcast owns and MSNBC yep
absolutely
I mean that's that's part of it this
it's vertical integration it's status
quo corporatism it did this has been
something we've been dealing with for a
long time now let me let me mention even
with them almost no corporate media
coverage of the gutting of net
neutrality at the beginning of the Trump
administration there were still millions
of comments submitted to the FCC about
it imagine if there was a serious
conversation on corporate media about
net neutrality what the levels of
support would be yeah I mean that's
definitely another problem I mean I live
in Texas which is of course a GOP
bastion be fair and to and of course it
just really annoyed me as a staunch
internet rights advocate considering
that uh senators Cruz and Cornyn or
blindly taking ISP donations and they're
like well we don't really need this
because yeah it's it's disgusting and
that's part of the I mean this goes to
another meta issue which is how politics
are financed which we've been we've been
talking about as well it's very very
depressing but glad that you brought it
up today yeah
okay David uh take care man okay you too
thanks for the call